[Music]  well Here I am again at the offseason  lounge just needed a fifth quarter to  make my comeback I for one loved hanging  out with all of my buddies here which is  cool this is the losers Club we'll look  at what Aaron Rodgers sent up in here  speak for yourself a regular Cutler's  [Music]  beer me and it's intercepted by the  floor I want to have a drink ready for  the Texans when they get here so they  know it's they belong don't feel bad  we all thought you'd be here a lot  sooner this is for NFL players only yes  playing Kansas City for the Jeep young  keeps is not PC and I played for  watching I know I bet the winners aren't  even having that much fun anyway